the new family Lee proposal on Capitol
Hill is raising awareness about the
challenges facing new parents the cradle
act is what it's call was introduced
yesterday by Republican senators Joan
Joni Ernst and Mike Lee it's being
praised by Ivanka Trump the legislation
joins bills by Republicans and Democrats
to address a problem the lawmakers agree
urgently needs a solution Nancy Cordes
sat down with Ernst Tinley that sounds
like a law for her she joins us now from
Nancy good morning with instantly good
morning you know it's hard to believe
but it's been more than 25 years Gail
since Congress passed its last piece of
Family Leave legislation meantime every
other industrialized nation provides a
set amount of paid time off after the
birth of a child but now Ernst Tinley
and many others think the stars might be
aligning here on Capitol Hill thanks
everybody very much Tuesday's
announcement by Senators Ernst and Lee
added two more Republican voices to a
debate long dominated by the left
families of course are the bedrock of
our society it's giving both sides hope
that this year will be different this
issue is now part and it's the center of
public discourse in this country which
is great it's an issue that's been
championed by President Trump
let's support working families by
supporting paid family leave at the
urging of his daughter Ivanka the world
has shifted and our policies need to
reflect that shift proponents think her
interest could help push a compromise
across the finish line the way her
husband's passion for criminal justice
reform did last December tell me a
little bit about how the two of you
ended up working together on this
Republicans Ernst and Lee called their
proposal the cradle' Act it would allow
new parents to use their own Social
Security savings to help finance time
off so you can take one two or three
months of parental leave and as a
consequence of that choose to delay your
retirement date by two four or six
months is this something that would
apply to caring for a sick relative a
parent as well right now it just applies
to the adoption of a child or the birth
of a child we're very focused on
parental leave Democrats have a
different proposal their family act
would Institute a small payroll tax to
provide up to 12 weeks to care for any
loved one Democrats say the GOP plan
creates a false choice between
retirement savings and paid leave I
respectfully but very strongly disagree
with them you say that to anyone who
would have the opportunity to use this
that would be news to them when you say
they're gonna add for six months to
their retirement date that's not
insignificant a lot of folks will focus
on Oh thee and the retirement age but
oftentimes we don't talk about that baby
it is important that we focus on that
too and not just think about maybe I'm
going to have to work another month or
two or three but focus on the benefits
that will come to that child as well you
think this could have a lifelong impact
on the babies most definitely very few
people would disagree with that but the
question is can the two sides find a
compromise I asked the Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell yesterday whether
he's committed to holding a vote on paid
family leave this year he said it's too
early to say it just depends on what his
colleagues come up with John Nancy you
thank you